sandy is taking a cab in New York City
the taxi fare includes a base charge of
$2 50 as soon as you enter the cab plus
an additional 250 per mile traveled if
sandy starts off with a $20 bill takes
the cab for five miles and leaves a $1
tip how much money will she be left with
well let's first just think about how
long how much this five mile cab ride is
going to cost her so the cost so cab cab
I'll call it the cab fare
cab fare so it's going to be two dollars
50 just when you get into the cab plus
$2 50 per mile plus $2 50 per mile well
she's going to go for five miles five
miles times $2 fifty two dollars right
this way times two dollars fifty two
dollars fifty per per mile so the cab
fare here is just going to be two dollar
fifty two dollar fifty this to our 50
plus five times 250 let's see five times
250 that is $12 and fifty
$12 $12.50 250 plus $12.50 is going to
be $15 so just the cab fare is going to
be $15 and then sandy gives a one dollar
tip so fair fair plus tip is going to be
equal to the cab fare $15 plus $1 which
is equal to $16 so then answering the
question how much money would she be
left with with a $20 bill well we could
write her change is going to be she's
going to give a $20 bill the fare is the
fare plus tip is $16 plus minus 16 so
she's going to have $4 left in change